[Music]
hey we're back and if you recognize that
song there's a pretty good chance you
already know there's a new push to
legalize marijuana nationwide at the
federal level the house passed a bill
now sitting with the senate but whether
it passes or not official acceptance of
the drug seems to be on the rise with
companies like amazon ending testing for
many job seekers and the major sports
leagues easing restrictions too major
league baseball no longer bans marijuana
the nba has relaxed its testing
requirements and the nfl is actually
funding research on the drug's health
benefits
however cannabis still carries the
unmistakable whiff of stigma for those
who personally use it more than 50 years
after the war on drugs began here's what
that stigma looks like today and what it
may take to change it
[Applause]
in almost every state in america the old
laws against marijuana have been
rewritten
but when it comes to talking about it
one question what's the question brother
how often do you consume cannabis we
found that new laws or not most people
seem to be following an old playbook
just say no to drugs wait this is your
official that's my official position
don't ask don't tell yeah i love about
it you can't say it yeah you seem a
little bit uncomfortable admitting it
um
i suppose i'm dancing around there
you're dancing around yeah and when
people do open up as some did i
definitely got high a lot over kovid
it turns out that laws can change in an
instant but worries about being
stereotyped as a cannabis user are a lot
harder to shake i mean i'd probably feel
weird if my mom saw this
this is your brain on drugs if you were
a kid in the 80s and 90s as i was you
grew up on a steady diet of anti-drug
programs and public service
announcements
if you use pot
you're not using your brain pot was also
a primary target of the drug war
something else i experienced firsthand
when one of president reagan's drug task
forces busted my own father for dealing
what was and still is a banned substance
under federal law a lot has changed with
some form of legalization in 47 states
but so much has not
no one in congress openly uses cannabis
and it can be problematic when a fortune
500 ceo lights up i mean it's legal
right it's totally legal okay after elon
musk appeared to smoke a joint on the
joe rogan experience podcast tesla's
stock value plummeted but as
legalization spreads a growing list of
celebrities and athletes have put a
different face on the industry even
former republican house speaker john
boehner has changed his stance on
marijuana as he told john dickerson last
year on cbs sunday morning i'd drink red
wine if somebody wants to smoke a joint
or
eat a gummy that's really none of my
business and now a politician from
louisiana is going one step further most
of the people police are arresting
aren't dealers but rather people with
small amounts of pot just like me gary
chambers is running for u.s senate and
in a first of its kind campaign video he
decided to light up to make a point
people just want to be within whatever
the norm is in society
and we haven't figured out how to
normalize this just yet some 7 million
people have watched the clip who as
chambers sees them are 7 million
potential converts to a new image of
cannabis
what do you think the image
of the cannabis consumer should be
a united states senator
he's already convinced his parents at
first my dad was like boy you're smoking
that dope
and i have to say i had to say dad is
not it's not the same as dope
but we got to have a real conversation
about it and if my 75 year old mom and
79 year old father
can evolve on the conversation then i'm
not really concerned what anybody else
thinks about it and so as we change our
laws to bring cannabis out of the courts
i just feel like it's something that we
should have always had so it should have
always been legal it's still going to
take some time and a change in our
culture to bring it out of the closet
how often do you use marijuana
oh
honestly
every day it took you a second before
you said yes were you thinking about
saying no i was i was but then i was
like you know what no why not it's it's
20 22 different times now
okay actually wait hold on i know what
you're trying to corner me on right now
i just i have some questions but but i
just want to say that that gentleman at
the end there who uses cannabis every
day you know a lot of people have a
glass of wine every night for dinner and
we're very accepting of that in our
society we're not yet accepting of
people using cannabis that regularly
people feel that stigma that's what it
is even though it's legal even though
it's legal widely legal yes so i have to
ask have you ever partook in this uh yes
so okay right so i did the story and
i've been asking other people so it's
fair to ask me and
all right i gotta say i feel the stigma
too yeah
okay so
you're saying yeah
right now
a lot of people say yabba-dabba-doo
because you know
yeah we've got a big wide audience all
over the country and the people there's
still a judgment around this drug so i
know i know oprah's trying to get so
yeah
and i have been flint stone before i
have not been flipped i have not been
flintstoned before no ball jokes aside
there is a stigma there is no
understanding why people won't admit it
if it is legal because there's a
difference between legalization getting
it out of the courts and then acceptance
getting it out of the closet and there's
going to be like a separate movement in
the years to come on that screen well
wait a second we have a no and a yes
i have before oh
but i didn't do it when i played because
i was too scared but here's the
difference a lot of people talk about
before not many people say i live a
productive life and i do it regularly
like that guy at the majority of my
friends do on a daily basis it's just
not my thing i'd rather take a glass of
wine all right yeah very good i
recommend martinelli's apple juice or
starbucks white hot chocolate you're
welcome america